viene scelto l'offerta è la vittima non
altro è un'altra dal dare questa letto
però possiamo applicare vicino
all'angolo ballo canto g della lombardia
ciao ragazzi bentornato una puntata di
vita [ __ ] è il tema della puntata di
oggi è freddo il ritorno
chi non ti mi avete chiesto quando
avremmo ripreso vita buttata me la
risposta è molto semplice
oggi per un evento così importante ho
pensato non solo di riprendere il
primissimo tema che sia mai stato fatto
all'interno di questa rubrica ma anche
di invitare uno spin e molto molto
speciale sto parlando di una persona che
quando si tratta di dare dei consigli e
molto molto capace e spesso seguito i
suoi rubrica un pochino meno capace a
seguirli
vabbè ci sta comunque tommaso tozzi ciao
a tutti possiamo subito dire una cosa
che naturalmente non siamo negli studios
di casa mia insomma di studio spiega sai
che dà valore
diciamo che abbiamo appena finito di
girare un video sul suo canale
mi sto candidando mi sto dina bagno
invito a seguirlo siamo buttati su
tuorli se sotto ci sta il link alla sua
puntata in modo da non perdere quello
che ascolteremo sono dei messaggi su
facebook come hanno inviato delle
persone paolo costa lo show del web è
esatta del tri guardanti in questo caso
il tema della friends on
poi mi spieghi perché volevo fare
l'interno bricalli donando amore tu
freddo nato non si sempre grandi pacche
sulle spalle la cantina dopo a cui
pensare e possiamo invece nella lontana
smog
io non so se vi fosse la rete ma non
avere tutto questo a piste ball hortal
incidendo qualcosa di sarkò ha iniziato
con il pensionato mila volte lascia
stare i grandi banche nelle spalle anche
sulle palle sono più una cosa messaggio
senti scusa mantovani perché era lui
senti ci sono dei mobili da portagli
sono arrivati 32 pacchi io non capisco
se eletto assistente una cosa così
capisco che c'è uno sconosciuto a casa
sua per lo stesso conosciuti e meno di
24 ore fatte la mattina ci siamo tutti
gli altri una madonna adesso se mi
rimane the public relation mettere i
propri mobili è più usato con più puri
chiesto per favore prima di andar altro
messaggio che a guardà settima zucchero
stesso per frigo e comunque portato il
cane partiamo subito un frammento vai
c'è un bus all'ospite ero
innamoratissimo di noia compagni di
classe quindi un giorno mi feci coraggio
scrissi il classico bigliettino chi
vuole mettere con me contatto di
cartelline risi e merino lei non solo
fece una grossa x1 ma sopraggiunse
perché sei tutto e poi concluse con un
ps gli fa eco pianali compiti di
matematica e poi le fece anche cucchiari
colpiti di la pratica il tempo a nola il
brutto moderato aveva in prima media
abbiamo tutti quella fase un po
parecchio blu io ancora sto vivendo in
cui certi che armi a casa dicendo ho
intenzione di farmi cat
e aggiunge ha ovviamente dopo una
settimana si fidanza con un'altra ad è
mai capitato di avere ragazze cioè nel
momento in cui c'è molto gentile con una
ragazza pensando che non ci possa essere
alcun tipo di problema del patto il
cammino stato tutto e io ho più
spasimanti donne e gli uomini
questo vuol dire cioè controllo perciò
vogliamo semplicemente sono stata freddo
nata con il semplice invio di questa
canzone
ascolta il ritornello il nostro pianeta
ci stupisce la sempre a noi non
pubblicità ok se lo merita ci stupisce
sarà mai cambiare
[Musica]
no
chi è
[Applauso]
[Musica]
eppure mai niente
riprenderò a me della pubblicità del
teatro grande tatto da parte sua casa
commentando la ragazza tanto di dover
partire dalla casa a trasferirmi in
diamante o dispare regioni a seguito di
un giorni di parigi e niente una volta
che la svizzera a terra o semplicemente
bloccato o maradona
eppure non ci ricade la prendo questa è
la cattiva è grazie a lei ma anche delle
foto ti nego non so dove andare ma l'ho
affrontata mandando una foto non mi sa
di un punto cioè mentre dico questo ma
puoi dire quello dell'ingaggio
[Musica]
abbiamo dovuto la prendiamo la sala
santi commenti nei panni della ragione
che ricevono poco più distante o vedrà
quindi un accappatoio e del sangue
attendo ero innamorato una ragazza e mi
disse che anche a qualcosa per me in
tanti anni che era uno square naturali e
lapidi pensavo fosse uno scherzo perché
ci aveva fatto una cosa simile ma
burrona nella vittoria di un panorama
più cos'è questo è per noi ci sono
ricorse al panorama quel tutto il native
merda che scherza mattina parlando
a me piaceva cioccolato non ci stava
provando tante cose da analizzare
tu hai delle preferenze riguardo al gong
leinbach sì con un eco molto più grande
ed internazionale ciao ciao vivevano
lavigne luci ne parlano in mano perché
voglio batterli e diritti of renzo nata
da tutti il re che italia che cava che
fate andare cercando maria de roma e
dannoso quanto mi conosce quel settore
baffi lo so ma che non disegnano una
volta della musica buttata nel sito quel
fango ed è lì hanno questo teniamo
poligono bene poi però appena e di e
anche di ultimamente mi sto occupando
della prima struttura
a seguire le nostre preferenze sappiate
che ci sta o la linea o comunque a casa
c'è il senso un appartamento da empire è
una persona dire di no
praticamente le viene a casa mia
durante una cena con amici si fa
bloccare dal mio mio amico e dai nostri
messaggi oppure sei mesi prima vincent
aosta nazione allo scritto un mio amico
che mi avrebbero forte l'economia ha
deciso di tagliare i rapporti non ho
preso quella permette è andare ad una
inguaribile se lui non aveva il telefono
questa ragazza con la quale si stanno
progettando un subalterno non legge che
a questo suo amico appena mandato un gol
ben 3 a questa qui e là rosicato ormai
un utente quando non le trovo male
parole trovo male quando le volevo
tromba perché volevo fare un batticarne
di precisione lasciato questa ragazza
tutti benissimo dato è sempre è un
giorno ma titolati tra suo testo o
compagnato
lei è molto ho capite effetto in alto la
testa stavo male che l'unica cosa che ho
fatto e guarda negli occhi e scappare o
course così tanto che tutti gli farebbe
da allora prima casa ti odio veramente
davanti a questi volta selezionati
grazie a lei totalizzato volte di forte
e reso un futuro di loro si dice no ok
niente che ha conosciuto dai ragazzi che
mi hanno senso lato ma poi ho capito che
dall altra gente che passa la vita col
padre da donne cioè marzo c che l'ha già
data per meglio dire la sveltina sotto
il portone migliorata è fatta
trombato nell'atrio del bottone
l'ascensore tener autoscale antinolfi
traffico e offrire cantina tutto il suo
parma la portiamo il portiere come i
compagni di visiva che stanno sentendo
con questione faresti tutto bene tutto a
posto lo diceva così ace tutti i fumi
sparisce ma allora gli ho scritto ma ci
sente ma come mai sia sparito c'è
qualcosa che non va ma non dovrebbe
andare bene
insomma includere temi po sparito
quelle cose che mi hai detto perché ci
sono ancora cosa non dovrebbe esserci
riferiva di vedo ma che facevo l'avere
un casino ma questo verso questo tutte
ste cose che mai detto ma ci sta no non
è un problema mio ha detto senti ma che
dobbiamo fare il senso ma questo non sei
tu sono io
secondo la sorella possiamo rimanere
amici non voglio perderti nel mio
percorso
non voglio soffrire non voglio far
soffrire te tu sei troppo ho paura di
innamorarmi e siamo abituato a poter
avere talmente tanto che non ci
accontentiamo più di una cosa sola si
dice vuoi che cerchi di stephen ci ha
provato a lanciare un pezzo di merda su
un ventilatore cesp lode ed è quello che
fa la gente spara stella e poeta
romantico mentre la pelle d'oca
questo ventilatore di feci quindi per un
caffè è quasi diventato una roba ma si
formerebbe un trasloco sono più moderno
allora io sono entrata nella scienza o
da tanti anni fa uno in più della mia
voce una delle ferie al più che salute
avvocati e quando mi sono proprio
informata e quindi sono andati antivirus
o lui alcuno provare a fare
qualcos'altro
io ovviamente non ci sono stato della
messa piccolina non ci sono collassate
brega monte successo del pcc ha capito
già fatto per me ma a fornire uno
rientra invece sono riuscita alla grande
di lei sono uscita alla grande 13 anni
ho detto che mi piaceva fare mi piace è
questo qua il pretesto 1 quando ai
granata il ruolo degli anni a 13 anni
scusami agli ottavi l'analisi è stato
diciamo questa miglioria parte perché
avevamo mai pensato anzitutto sotto i
camini e poi perché comunque appetiti
che aggiunge mi devi immedesimati nel
tredicenne c'è un film che non mi vedo
come si chiama the spiega quando ci
dicono il bambino ti prendeva in giro
perché in realtà una cotta per te è una
catona sarta e noi cresciamo tra avviati
da questa idea che chi ci tratta male ci
viene indietro e non è vero e noi
cresciamo con questa cosa che hanno ne
scrive allora mi piace non mi scrive
perché molto probabilmente
un trenino a casa sua o 15.000 grazie
ciao ragazzi si segnala una città che
siamo con francesco che io chiamo nel
mito di avere uno sugar daddy non ti
manca da di riversare mollo tutto mi
fondo per lottare perché noi siamo
abituati quando erano piccoli di dover
fare i bravi perché poi il signore con
la barba una volta all'anno sulle
ginocchia del quale ci saremmo seduti
doveva convincere di essere stati dei
bravi bambini e allora lui ci avrebbe
fabriani questo comunque è il principio
che sta alla base dello sugar daddy
insieme non siamo presenti con questi
due mediani che comunque sono tra piatti
secondo me a 16 anni bisogna mandare
tutti canali che io sento un vuoto
dentro uscire di analisi ed è con questo
che ringrazio per essersi prestato a
darmi una mano a riprendere con questa
canzone di una cosa che farà il video
una cosa che faremo insieme portato gli
scherzi di mido veramente andare sul suo
canale a vedere l'intervista che mi ha
fatto non aspettate comunque di meglio
molto grazie per la tris gravina
io poi sempre vi ricordo che qua sotto
l'avrete tutti quanti link di tommaso
quello che vi posso dire per
rintracciarlo troviate in quello che è
un grande inizio
io vi invito a scrivere questo canale
attivate le campane delle notifiche come
sempre noi ci vediamo la prossima
domenica con un cuscino puntata